el presidente de eeuu donald trump se
negó a condenar las acciones de kyle
winehouse el adolescente blanco que
supuestamente mató a dos manifestantes
incluso el 25 de agosto hechos por los
que se encuentra detenido y acusado de
homicidio el joven que era simpatizante
de txanpi acudió a uno de sus mítines en
enero y ya de los manifestantes que
querían detenerle
fue una situación interesante vieron el
mismo vídeo que yo y él estaba tratando
de alejarse de ellos supongo parecía que
si se cayó y luego lo atacaron muy
violentamente del sunday de walk y negro
y eso es algo que estamos investigando
en este momento pero supongo que estaba
en grandes dificultades probablemente lo
habrían matado de europa
trouble the world out las polémicas
declaraciones de champ llegaron horas
antes de su visita de este martes aquí
no sea una localidad envuelta en tensión
desde que el pasado 23 de agosto un
policía blanco disparó siete veces por
la espalda al afroamericano ieco blake
la casa blanca dijo que don h no tiene
de reunirse con los familiares por su
parte el candidato presidencial
demócrata joe biden denunció los
violentos estallidos al margen de las
protestas anti racistas y acusó a su
rival de ayudar los disturbios
los incendios están ardiendo y tenemos
un presidente que aviva las llamas en
lugar de luchar contra ellas pero no
debemos quemar tenemos que construir
este presidente hace mucho tiempo perdió
todo el liderazgo moral en este país no
puede detener la violencia porque
durante años lo ha fomentado y así
forman a nueve semanas de las elecciones
presidenciales del 3 de noviembre los
ataques entre los dos candidatos siguen
subiendo de tono y muestran cómo será la
línea que tendrán como presidentes